return with me to the idea we covered
last lesson
i did warn you we looked at these do you
remember these guys
right um i gave you an example z1
and then i said well if you successively
multiply through by
what do we multiply by in this case
it was i wasn't it right every time you
multiply by i
you get this new complex number and i
asked you to consider with me
what the real and imaginary components
were and then we noticed this unusual
pattern that at least for these numbers
first second third fourth number we're
in the first second third fourth
quadrant it's almost
like it was planned to do that right so
we introduced this idea
that we can take these ordered pairs
place them onto
a cartesian plane like this right and
say oh
there's rotation going on these complex
numbers actually
are best easily understood in two
dimensions that's what we suggested
right
now what you've got here and if you want
to go back to where you uh did this you
know last lesson
what you've got here is what we call a
cartesian plane it's just got cartesian
coordinates on it
the x's and the y's are both
real numbers but then we extended it
even though the diagram looks materially
the same
we extended to say we can represent
complex numbers not talking about
a real x and a real y but talking on the
complex plane about these being
well just have a look at the coordinates
right
they're not really coordinates at all
see this guy here right 2 minus 5i
that's not
this part in this part that's a whole
hole's not the right word that's a
unified number 2 minus five i is one
thing that i'm considering together and
it represents a point on the plane
now some of you may have heard this uh
this language used before but
um cartesian plane right i was named
after french mathematicians anyone know
his name
rene cartesian plane we named the
complex plane or particularly a complex
plane when you put complex numbers on it
we name it after another french
mathematician his name was
jean-robert ar gand
a r g a n
d so we call this and you'll hear us say
this
and we might ask you in an assessment
right to plot on
an argand diagram
these complex numbers or do these uh you
know geometric
operations it's more or less synonymous
with the complex plane okay so if you
hear either of those phrases
they essentially mean the same thing so
now let's start to explore
what does this geometric idea unlock for
us what sort of this is a key
what doors does it open okay um if you
have a look at those
complex numbers that i gave you at the
start and um the operations i asked you
to do about this right
arithmetically we know what addition and
subtraction do to complex numbers
but now we can think about what does it
mean geometrically like when you do z1
plus z2
what does that look like z1 minus z2 and
so on right
so onto your complex plane i asked you
to do this
basically though i did add on something
which is implied
which is a line from the origin up to
our complex number z1 and z2 some of you
did that instinctively if you haven't
already that's fine
go ahead and add them on now and as i
said before and i'll say again
if you have more than one color on your
desk at the moment
this is going to be really helpful
you'll see why very shortly okay
so here are my z1 and my z2
now on this scheme
where is z one plus said two you
evaluated
what is it actually equal to four plus
three i
so you can see where this should be on
your complex plane on your argan diagram
could you go ahead and put that on
for me there's four plus three i
and i'm i'm calling it z3 just so i
don't have to keep on you know
giving it the actual numbers so i'm just
gonna describe that as z3
and there of course is our coordinate 4
plus
3i now i want you to look
at the geometry of what's going on what
is the visual relationship
between this new point up here is z3
and the numbers that sort of went into
it the numbers that contributed to make
it
right now maybe if you squint really
hard you might notice there's kind of
an implied shape underneath the origin
over there at the intersection between
the real and imaginary axis the origin
between our two points z1 and z2 that we
started with and
z3 up in the corner if we were to join
them in a polygon what
shape would that give us that would give
us a parallelogram can you visualize it
and there's a reason for this
right when you think about what it means
to add z1
to z2 what we're really doing is we're
kind of the fancy word is concatenating
we're putting together
these two operations as it were
z1 3 plus i takes you to this place on
the complex plane you can think of it
like a
set of instructions go here right on a
gps and then z2 tells you to do
something else
go one to the right that's what the real
part means and then two units
upwards that's what the imaginary part
means and so you can see there's this
literally parallel to where z2 was
over there so if you enact z1 as a
movement as a translation
and then if you enact z2 you end up with
z1 plus z2 and of course um addition by
the way
it's an operation that we can change its
order right does anyone remember how
long fancy word we learned in year seven
that means you can change the order of
operation you get the same altar can you
remember
commutativity when you say
two things are commutative you can
switch their order so
z1 plus z2 presumably is the same as
z2 plus z1 now visually that means
something
again right doing z1 and then z2
takes you to the same destination as if
you had done
z2 first and then z1 and that's why you
get a parallelogram
right we're preserving the fact that
these are parallel
and they're also the same length right
because we get them from z1
and z2 does this make sense okay so that
was
the first question i asked you to do
then i asked you to do a subtraction
z1 minus z2 where where is that what are
the what's the actual complex number
two yeah two minus i which uh if i did
it right
it's down here uh if you haven't already
go ahead and plot that onto your complex
plane on your argon diagram
if you did everything up in the first
quadrant because z1 and z2 were in the
first quadrant
apologies for that extend down your
imaginary axis so you can reach down to
there
okay now this one takes a little more
thought
to sort of wrap your head around but
hopefully given the introduction i just
gave you with this
you'll be able to make sense of what's
happening here
subtraction is just a special version
of addition you say that again
subtraction is just a special version of
addition if i said to you
eight take away three that'd be the same
as
eight plus plus what
it's it's say it again negative three
right a plus negative three and a take
away three same deal
now that means that everything all the
geometric intuition we developed
up with addition we can use it for
subtraction z1
i'm going to have to write this over
here i think our space
z1 minus z2 i can write a z1
plus the negative of z2
now geometrically what does that even
mean the the negative
of z2 we already know this from the real
number line right
if five's over here negative five's just
in the
opposite direction right versus left on
the complex plane we're a little more
uh nuanced then just left and right
we've got up and down we've got two
dimensions right
so if z2 is that red line over there
what's minus z2
instead of going to the right and up
it's going to be going
to the left and down so if you were to
take that left
downward complex number and then add it
to z1
well no surprises that you end up down
there do you see what's going on here
right if i were to just put a um i
didn't i didn't think of this beforehand
so now i'm just going to put it on there
this is minus z
two that that's what this thing is here
right
so you do z one first which is the blue
line
takes you there and then you do minus z
two and that takes you down
to the fourth quadrant right by the way
you know how you identified this
parallelogram that was on there before
there's a parallelogram here too it's
just a little more hidden where is it
can you
see it where did you say minus z2 went
again
what direction did it go in to the left
and then down
so so it's over here do you agree
there's minus z2 on the left hand side
so that's why here if i complete sorry
it's very messy but you get the idea
right
there's the parallelogram another one
right except it's down beneath
because we had this subtraction business
make sense
okay let's put that guy away now the
next thing i asked you to do was
some multiplication right again i'm
pressing you to think about not just
what the numbers tell you what are the
numbers by the way um go ahead and tell
me what 3 z1 is
it's uh 9 plus 3i
and then 3 plus 6i
right okay you're probably seeing where
i'm going here and you're like oh no my
complex plane is too small
go ahead and put these guys on as well
okay if you can fit them
if you can fit them try your best maybe
you're gonna
go off the page or something like that
that's okay go as far as you can
if we need to put these guys on as well
we said that
adding or subtracting complex numbers is
like doing
one complex number after another putting
the steps together
that's addition subtraction visually
what is multiplication
now i'm going to have to go over to a
different graph here's one i prepared
earlier
so there is um i kind of remember is
that one is that z2
that z1 right i got it right okay good
so when we go ahead and plot
uh three times that right yeah i'm not
i'm not just sort of randomly placed you
can see what i've done is
and again so i'm just gonna do a
screenshot here what's happening is
you do z1 but then multiplication by
three means you do it again
and then you do it one more time
multiplication is just repeated addition
right but a more generalized way of
thinking about it because you don't
always get like nice integer numbers
right
what if i had for instance and i'm going
to ask you to put your pens down for a
second just watch this so you can see
what's going to happen
what if i asked you to multiply by not
three but say
two and a half what would you predict
would be the result
let's go ahead and change it and see
what happens
did you see it that's why i asked you to
put your pens down
here's multiplication by three his
multiplication by two and a half or
multiplication by
one and a half we need better language
than just describing oh it's that number
of chunks because when you have
non-integer amounts
what's going on here what word would you
use to describe the relationship between
the purple complex number and the orange
one yeah go ahead the large moon with
the background
enlargement is a really good way to go
about it scale maybe all these are very
i'm happy to use all these you know
languages right here um by the way
though
uh did you say enlargement and i said
scale right probably the tricky thing
with enlargement is it assumes you're
getting
bigger what could i do to make my thing
smaller
what do i multiply by so yeah let's just
change that factor
right so that's why i think scale might
be maybe a it's it's a more
broader word that you can use okay um by
the way we already explored it but you
can see what happens if i go negative
my graph unfortunately i couldn't
program it to do what i wanted but you
can see where it's going right it's
going in the opposite direction now
because i've got a negative included in
my scale
this makes sense so it changes the
direction okay